Yes.
OK, but also provide the mic access.
Okay, so thank you all for joining.
Yeah.
Did the SINDHURA say something or?
Okay,
so today we will discuss on the major
shifts which are happening.
So last class we ended with the shifts.
So in the previous session,
to give a quick recap,
we looked at the evolution,
like what was waterfall,
then how it changed to agile.
And we also talked about the DevOps.
Coming in, etcetera.
So that was the evolution to understand
how the software development lifecycle
has majorly evolved over the years.
And we will be using a lot of,
Thanks.
I would request all of you to be on mute
if you don't have any questions to ask.
A.
so that the recording is clear for those
who want to revisit the recording later.
Okay,
so we were discussing on the evolution of
the SDLC as a whole,
and we saw the transition happening from
waterfall to agile to
Then comes the DevOps culture,
all those things.
So this evolution happened,
the major evolution was when we went in
for an incremental and iterative version.
And then this evolution under the AI
acceleration is what the entire course is
about. That's
We are going to see how the AI driven
change.
is affecting every phase of the software
life cycle,
not just the development or not just the
design or not just the final operations.
It's affecting every stage.
So we are going to see how that is
affecting the entire life cycle phases,
et cetera.
So before getting into.
Each phase,
we are having a few introductory classes.
In this, the first,
we understood the evolution in the
previous session. So this session,
we are going to see what are the major
shifts. So what we did previously,
and now what we are doing.
So that major shift
understanding is necessary.
So we look at the shifts and we will also
summarise the risks which are involved.
We will get into the risk at every phase
in detail,
but we will just have a basic
understanding of the risks which are
involved by because of the shifts which
are happening or how the entire
community should cope up or equip
themselves to manage these shifts,
et cetera.
So that is what will be our discussion
today. And in the upcoming classes,
I think next week we don't have a class
due to the Independence Day mandatory
holiday.
We have a class which is rescheduled to
21st Friday and the 22nd Saturday we'll
have a regular class.
So the next 4th and the 5th contact
session we will do a
The basics of AI.
That is.
in terms of understanding what is
required for a software engineering
aspects because
Even in the shift which we are going to
talk about, I wanted to do a shift,
a separate detailed shift on the cost and
economics.
But then I understood that if I need to
talk about tokens,
I need to talk about context memory,
we should have some basic understanding
of how the models work, how an LLM works.
What is a context memory? What is an MCP?
So some basic foundations is what is
required.
So we will have to have that to use those
tools.
Then only we can use those tools more
efficiently in all our phases.
So that module will cover the basics.
So we dedicate 2 classes. I will try to
do as much as justice as possible in
those two classes.
Other things we can probably take it as a
self-learning.
We will see how that can be taken up or
maybe we can have some additional
sessions as well.
So that would be the plan.
So today we'll talk about the shift and
the risk, and then we will shift,
talk about the foundations in the next
two classes.
So you are asking,
can we shift this class to different
timing?
Different timing in the sense,
what time do you want?
Ma'am, we were discussing about it.
So if 11.30 in the morning to 1.
30 afternoon or 2pm to 4pm,
is it feasible?
So you don't have any class in the
morning?
Morning we have one from 830 to 820 to
1020.
So we thought one hour gap if we get
maybe 1120 also you can start 1120 to 120
Hey.
EM.
is that.
Okay,
11 to 11 to 1 should work 11 or 1115 as
you said 1120 to 120 should work for me.
Give me some time.
I will cheque with the division on Monday
Okay.
and I will let you know.
I don't think you don't have a class with
other classes, forces, right?
No, we don't have any class there.
So what is the other two forces which is
happening?
Other 2 we have on cloud computing and we
have one on software architecture.
C.
And we can work on.
Wait, no,
I meant the timings for those posts.
Yeah.
The.
Okay, so one happens Sunday morning,
which is 820 to 1020 and the other
Read 1020.
happens 130 to 330 on Sunday afternoon.
Basically 2 classes on Sunday and two
classes on Saturday. So the Saturday one,
this class is in the evening for us.
So basically it's a lot of gap.
One class is in morning 830 and this
class is in the evening at 550. So yeah,
Yeah.
I agree. I mean, if we, if.
possible or we can shift this timing
tomorrow.
It should work. I mean,
right now at this moment,
I don't have any class in the morning
half. So we can shift this to the morning.
I will talk to the division.
One of you can write to the support
keeping me in the loop also.
So I will take it up with the WILP
division and see if this can be changed.
Sure, man. So,
support e-mail is support at the rate
that e-mail ID that what is the common
e-mail ID.
Yes, yes, support at WILP, yeah.
Okay, sure.
Yeah.
And yeah, on the assignment part, I will,
so we will start our first quiz one after
the five sessions, that is 21st and 22nd,
I plan to finish the two sessions, right?
So 23rd, I will start the quiz one,
which is only five basic sessions.
So it will be module one and module 2.
as for the course handout,
which is on the foundations and paradigm
shift, which we are discussing,
and the two foundations of AI and prompt
engineering.
So that will be the quiz syllabus.
So the quiz will start from 23rd.
Usually how the quizzes will be scheduled
is it will be available in your course
page in the e-learn.
Takshila model page.
It will be MCQ questions.
There will be 20 questions, which will be,
there will be more questions in the
question bank,
but each of you will get only 20
questions. And that is for five marks.
you will have to attend the quiz.
It will be open for a week,
but once you start,
you have to finish within 30 minutes of
time limit.
So the time limit for the quiz will be 30
minutes,
but you can start at any time within that
week. So for example, for quiz one,
I'm planning to open by 23rd of August.
So it will be open for one week that is
still 31st of August.
So during that time period,
you can log in anytime.
and attend the quiz. But once you start,
there will be only one attempt and it
will be 30 minutes for you.
So that is how you have to attend the
quiz. So quiz two,
we will do after the mid sem. Quiz one,
it will be a running assignment,
which I will talk about it a little later.
So probably after we start with phases,
it will be the assignment final
submission will be towards the end,
but it will have different phases.
So we will start the assignment around
the 7th week, around that time.
But you can focus more on the mid sem and
we can do the assignment.
post the medicine part.
It will be one quiz, sorry,
2 quizzes and one assignment.
That's how the course will go.
Okay,
the complete schedule I will post it.
So the...
First quiz,
which is scheduled between August 10th to
20th, that will be for us,
it will be happening from 23rd of August
for this particular course.
Thanks.
So 2 quizzes, 55 marks,
each 10 marks and 20 marks for the
assignment.
It will be 1 continuing assignment,
but there will be phases. There will be,
we can call it as modules,
which will have separate marks.
So that will be 20 marks.
So topics for quiz one will be module one
and two.
That is whatever we are discussing till
CS5.
So I will open the quiz after contact
session 5 CS5.
So that is when you will have the quiz.
So all topics discussed between.
CS1 to CS5.
Okay,
all this I will put an announcement once
I enable it so you don't have to note it
down or remember.
All those things will be coming to you
through the announcements. Right?
Assignment we will talk about in detail.
It's going to be a little bit of hands-on
and more of a reflection assignment.
So we will, in assignment,
the idea is to pick up a problem
statement, try out all the phases,
all the SDLC phases,
whatever is possible within our local
environment,
try out all the phases and reflect on how
it is happening,
what are the challenges faced.
That's how the assignment will be.
structured,
and each phase will have separate
reflection questions.
Each phase will have a submission.
We will do it incrementally,
and the final closure will happen towards
the end of the course,
that is before CS1314, that time frame.
Okay,
so usually what I do is I give the
assignment in the initial,
that is before the mid sem itself in the
6th or the 7th week,
but it will be a running assignment where
they will do it incrementally,
where the learners will do it
incrementally.
And the final submission will happen
around
the CS 1340. So that 15,
16 weeks you are completely free and
spend time to prepare for your
comprehensive exam.
So that is how it will be planned.
Yeah.
Okay, I think that clears.
Yes, so.
Hello, Mam. GUDIYA.
Yes, yeah, yes, Vivian.
Yeah, ma'am, I had one doubt. Yeah,
so I had one doubt,
like the reference material that you have
shared,
that is for our knowledge or it will be
in,
we have to go through it for the
examination purpose as well.
Yes,
so I'm collating all the reference
material in one of the loop pages,
just for your easy reference,
though it is there in the end of the
slide also.
So it is for you to go through in detail.
The topic in the PPT will cover that only,
but it will be in a more shorter way,
more
information will be in terms of
discussion.
But when it comes for preparation for the
exam, you might need more details.
So that is why those references are
mentioned. It is good that, say,
for example, if there are a few papers,
I might talk about the crux of the paper
only in the class.
It might be 40, 50 pages of paper,
which you might have time or not have
Okay.
time to read through the entire paper.
So depending on your individual
requirement,
you can decide how you want to go through
it.
Or you can use AI tools like Notebook LM
Play Ali.
or others to also understand the crux.
what is the content for such research
papers, et cetera.
Certain, I mean, to answer your question,
there is no one answer.
OMKAR.
It is like you have to decide on a case
to case basis.
Certain reference materials are just,
you have to have a glance of it,
but certain things you have to spend more
time. That's how it will be.
Okay, ma'am, thank you so much.
It also depends on individual to
individual. Yeah,
Mmh.
Google form might have prepared the form,
it is ready, but the participants,
they have not circulated it.
I'm thinking to circulate it myself
itself, WILP division,
they wanted to circulate it with your
profiles, but they have not done it.
So I think since we have a gap now,
I will roll it out in this week myself
only to your individual WILP e-mail IDs.
That is for us to have an understanding.
Also get some few inputs on what you
would like to have your topics,
certain inputs I want from the crowd.
So that is what the Google form is about.
I will do it myself this week.
Yeah.
So PPT content and reference materials
are fine because I didn't find any book
which is...
completely covering all the aspects.
If you have any recommendations,
you can share it with me.
We can mutually see if that is suitable
and then maybe we can have a discussion
about it. But generally,
We can go with the PPT and references
mentioned.
Yeah.
Also,
I am planning to do a few office hours,
that is tutorial sessions.
That is apart from your regular classes.
There is no,
that is those tutorial hours will be one
hour duration.
It will be on a weekday evening,
that is Thursday evening or Friday
evenings mostly.
It will not cover anything.
So all your questions,
which are general operational in nature,
or you want to talk something about the
course,
that is something we can have mutual
discussions. You can join.
Once the assignment is published,
that tutorial power can be used to
discuss the assignment.
So usually I do it one hour.
Four hours I will do,
two before the mid-sem,
two after the mid-sem.
The general discussions,
I will not cover any topics.
So if some of you are not available or
you don't have any active questions that
day, you may not join that.
It is just for our reference,
just a normal interaction outside the
class that.
That is how it is.
So those office hours we can utilise to
discuss any of your questions,
or you want to talk something about the
course,
or want to discuss something about the
WILP programme, et cetera,
we can use that particular session. Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
OK, with that, let me get into the course.
So,
I'm going to talk about the five major
shifts which we are discussing. OK,
and the cost shift.
I asked a few questions in the last class,
and I...
kind of all whatever shifts you think are
there are actually merged to one of these
or aligned with one of these five cores
or five shifts.
The one thing which is not listed here is
the cost aspect.
So I have the cost shift is something
which I'm thinking to cover it in a
little more detailed debate.
Today we will.
Just touch up on the base,
so I will cover that as a major shift in
what major shift in the Software
economics in detail,
so starting with the first step.
shift. So this has been one of the major
shift I would say,
or the shift which happened more faster
compared to the other shift.
So let's imagine that you are leading,
each of you are leading a software team
five,
six years ago when there was no LLM or.
generative AI.
So one of the first questions in every
planning meeting we will ask,
just six years or seven years before when
there was,
imagine a world where we don't have the
generative AI.
The first question is,
what can we afford to build? Right?
So that was the first question which
would be discussed.
What can we afford to build in the first
iteration? Is feature one necessary?
Is feature 2 necessary?
That's how engineering time was scarce.
Every feature came with a cost.
Every decision required a trade-off.
So that is why we had this concept of MVP
scope cutting, right?
Or talk about only the prototype,
UX first thinking,
prioritizations were there.
So all these were foundational.
They were not best practises,
but they were all survival strategies.
Right, but today we are,
we have to ask a different question
because the Development effort is no
longer.
the bottleneck we have to
ask different kind of questions, right?
So the bottleneck is no longer writing
code.
The bottleneck is deciding what should
exist.
Oh.
ensuring it has the behaviour.
as intended as it is,
and preventing the system from collapsing
under the own complexity, et cetera.
So if you look at,
I will discuss 2 examples about this
shift. Think about,
go back to those five years back or six
years back when you were leading a
project.
team.
How do you approach a minimal viable
product that time?
What would be questions we will be
discussing?
Minimum viable product is what we will
first show to the customer, right?
So we will spend a lot of time discussing
should the feature A go to the release?
Can we postpone feature B to the next
sprint?
Do we really need feature C at this point
in time? Why? No, why do you want that,
right?
Because we were discussing more on that.
five, six years back.
Why was that reason the cost cutting or
the scope cutting aspects?
We were parallelly,
one team was working on the version A and
the other team would be parallelly
working on version B and then we will
reach out to the customer with both the
versions and see which works well.
right?
Because every additional feature
represented days or weeks of engineering
effort.
Instead of spending weeks deciding which
single version to build, now with the AI,
we are able to build multiple
alternatives simultaneously.
Right, so there is no wireframes,
no mockups.
We directly go with working applications,
and they are put in front of the end
users or customers.
And then the inputs are taken,
determines what works well,
and we are able to go with the approach.
So
The example one which we talks about the
MVP scope cutting is no longer works.
It is we are able to give working
prototypes parallel versions now with the
help of AI, right? The other,
if you look at the technical,
design document side of it.
That's another fascinating shift,
I would say. Design documents, if you,
how many of you have spent on
documentation,
considerable time on documentation?
Okay, ASMITA says, okay.
Sheikh AKSHAYA,
so all of you who all of you who have
raised hands five, six years before.
Oh.
When you wrote documentation,
who were the primary users of that
documentation?
Or why did you write documentation for?
stakeholders to freeze requirements and
customers.
other DevOps, sorry, Dev people,
other stakeholders in our team,
senior leaders.
So we wanted all of us to be in the same
page.
We want to freeze and start with a
development effort.
So if you look at this thing,
All the inputs which you have mentioned,
so Ajay Babu has mentioned end customers,
Vishal other devs,
SINDHURA has mentioned project scope for
new developers.
So all of you have mentioned only humans,
right?
So we were writing documents primarily
for humans.
other humans so that all of us are in
sync, all of us are in the same page.
And we want to ensure that there is no
misunderstanding or miscommunication
between us, the team,
so that no efforts go wasted.
That was the primary idea for.
the documentation. So earlier,
it was designed for humans.
They aligned the teams.
They clarified what architecture should
be designed.
They reduced the miscommunication among
developers. But today,
if you look at the spec-driven
development,
which we are going to explore,
we are writing documents or the spec is
written for AI. Design documents,
the emphasise on design documents is much
more even important.
Though it was quite important for the
human,
there was some implicit understanding we
had as a team,
so you don't mention minute details.
But now the design document or the spec
document becomes much more even important
because the audience is shifted from
humans to AI.
They are no longer just documents for
engineers.
They are becoming specifications for
coding agents.
They are becoming specifications for mini
AI.
tools. So every ambiguity,
every missing constraint,
every vague requirement gets amplified by
missions that execute at incredible speed,
right?
So poor documentation will no longer
cause slow development,
but it will cause a architectural mistake
or a decay. So precision of intent,
what we have to cover,
becomes more valuable than the speed of
implementation.
So when I discuss this particular point,
there is one movie.
Um...
scene which comes to me,
which is the robo movie in Tamil.
I don't know how many of you have seen
that. There is this actor,
Rajinikanth's movie,
where he designs a robo.
And when he just tests this in the real
world,
first time, okay,
he goes and asks the robot to switch on
the TV, right?
So he mentions it in a very colloquial
way,
like he speaks to his friend to switch on
the TV,
but the robot understoods in a different
way and just.
breaks the entire TV. So some of you,
if you have seen the movie,
you will relate it to it, right?
So the instructions we give to a human,
our co-peers, the leader,
or other stakeholders cannot be the same
instructions we give to the AI.
Right, so that's very,
that's a very message important message
we should take, and...
How many of you can relate to this
example?
I hope at least a few miss.
Right.
It's.
I hope some of you would have watched
that scene right, so,
so basically the takeaway is this
instructions cannot be.
Less precise, it has to be more precise.
Documentations become more important,
and the precision of intent is more
valuable than the speed of
implementations. Yeah, yeah, the name.
Ritul has reminded me.
I was just thinking in the back of my
mind. I just forgot the name. Yeah.
Right.
Okay,
Sheikh Ashram Parveen mentions even in
the current project also it's mandatory
to provide document to QA team client to
have a clear picture.
So the point I'm trying to make is the
documentation remind that is true, but
The documentation was for human
stakeholders, right?
It can be in multi-modal, as you said,
it can be a full-fledged Figma file,
it can be a Swagger mode,
or it can be even a full text document,
open API specification,
it can be anything.
But it was meant for human readers.
So it is okay if you don't miss a few
things.
That is if you miss a few things also,
it's okay because you as worked as a team,
they have a context based on which they
would have worked with you.
So those things get missed.
So for example,
I recently read a LinkedIn post.
I wanted to share the snapshot with all
of you, but I will do it later.
So this post mentioned that they were
looking at a few AI based developed
applications and they found a common
pattern,
common mistake in all those applications.
One was the hard coding of API links.
Okay,
usually if you work on the front end side,
you want to call back end APIs.
We used to have a API file which has all
the URIs of the APIs mentioned in that
file.
So that's the best practise we follow.
So whenever we have a.
want to call multiple APIs.
We say we have a microservices
architecture at the back end.
We don't have a monolith.
We call multiple services or we even call
some third party APIs.
The API URL link is something which needs
to be, it's not hard.
coded in throughout the code cycle.
There is one place where you will see
that code is available.
It's like a config API config.js file.
I'm just talking about example web
application.
And then whenever there is a change in
the config API config,
you change only one file.
and that's how you maintain.
That's a best practise.
But when they looked at many of the AI
written code,
this particular team understood there are
a lot of hard coding of information.
It's spread out across multiple places.
And second is
There is something called as AI slop,
which I will discuss in the later page,
or also supply chain problems that they
are not using real libraries.
They are creating fake libraries,
or they are trying to configure or use
libraries which are not active.
or which are obsolete,
and that is also causing a problem.
So these are some problems we are facing,
which we are going to discuss in detail.
But the point I want to make here is we
don't mention these small,
small things when we write documentation
for humans. But for AI,
we have to be more precise.
respect-driven development aspect.
There are many best practises.
You have to add it in the context.
That is what is more important.
So we have to be more cautious,
more vigilant when we are actually trying
to write documents.
That is what I wanted to convey through
the second example.
Okay, there are a few more examples also.
What has changed,
basically technical depth,
the word we discussed last week, right?
The word technical depth itself has
changed. Traditionally,
technical depth means the team ran out of
time.
We will do this later.
We'll skip the test for now.
We'll refractor after launch.
So the depth came from code which was not
written or what mainly because lack of
time.
But now technical depth is coming from
too much code because lack of
verification of that.
We don't have the bandwidth to verify
that too much of code.
Thousands of lines are generated in
minutes. Entire module seems to work.
So the developer is happy and just
approves and sends the code.
But line by line checking is,
there is a fatigue also,
and it's not manually possible within
that.
So dependencies, no one fully understands.
Logic, nobody fully feels responsible.
So that is where the technical depth also
has changed.
So dev effort is no longer the bottleneck,
but the problem is this also, right?
Then the software engineer role itself
keeps changing, right?
So that is the major shift, I would say.
Okay, so let's go to the next basic shift.
Yeah, yes, unit test, of course, yes,
we are having a fatigue,
human verification. ABINAYA,
that's a very good idea, actually.
That's what AWS Kiro follows.
So that's one agent who writes the code.
There is other agent which...
test or even there are multiple agents
they can spawn to do that, right?
But again,
there are a few problems in that as well.
So when you, we have that number,
there is some circular validation
prevention errors.
We will discuss those in detail in our
quality assurance module.
So.
Yes, of course,
that's the way forward and that's the
practise which has been followed right
now,
but that's also not a silver bullet or
it's not as easy as we say one.
LLM will write, LLM will test,
we'll just observe. Still,
there has to be a human in the loop
points which are...
which has to be there and we are still
not reached that stage where we can just
hand it over to agents and relax back.
We look at those problems.
That's exactly right.
What we are heading towards that is what
every,
there will be one LLM agent which will do
each of their tasks.
And we have to define our human
checkpoints towards that.
So the next shift I'm going to talk about
is about how the roles have changed.
So the role earlier, if you look,
there is developer who only writes the
code.
Customer shares the requirement.
Product manager writes the PRD document.
Then they become the JIRA stories.
Developers translate those stories into
code. QA writes the test cases.
DevOps packages and deploys the
application.
SRE teams monitor it in production.
And each phase ends with a handoff.
So this division of labour is what we
have been practising for decades.
Because every activity here required a
specialised human effort,
different kind of skills, different tools,
different expertise.
But let me ask you one question.
What happens when AI can perform much of
the work across every phase of the
Software Development Life Cycle?
Can, so same question, right?
OK, what is PRD requirement? OK,
PRD is product requirements document.
Right. If AI can write code,
if one LLM can generate the test,
another LLM can create the infrastructure,
span the new infrastructure,
and they can even set up the DevOps
pipeline, deployment pipeline.
What will be the roles?
We have the context of everything.
We need to only monitor, right?
AI engineer would be the new role, right?
So if you, what will happen in that case?
You will be responsible for end to end.
Your boundaries between roles will start
to disappear.
Right.
Software engineering itself is moving
from specialisation. That is,
I'm a front end five,
six years back when I used to take this
full stack application course.
People would say, ma'am,
I'm a front end engineer.
I don't know much about back end,
so you please concentrate on.
the front end back end part more.
There will be database engineers who will
say,
I don't even know how a browser works,
so I would need more time on the React
and other aspects of it.
So we were focusing on the syntax,
we were focusing when we want to learn
skills,
we were more aligned to the syntax,
we were more aligned to the semantics,
how this works.
works, et cetera. Right now,
instead of owning one stage of the
process,
engineers increasingly own an entire
customer problem.
So AI agents are becoming those ones who
execute those individual tasks.
Humans are there to provide the judgement,
the direction, and take accountability.
Right, so the developer,
the product manager,
and the developer blur comes in.
Right.
So if you look at the previous pre-era,
product manager gathered requirements,
wrote user stories or the team of
managers, prioritised what has to go,
then the developer translated into APIs,
user interfaces, code, etc.
Now you have a customer interview in the
morning, you gather the requirements,
you write the PRD,
you give it to an AI assistant,
you are able to generate the schema,
API definitions, user interface mock-up.
So the handoff is just no longer a
document.
It's an executable prototype, right?
So that is becoming blur. More than,
I would say,
more than the product manager developer
blur.
The blur is more on the developer QA and
operations, right? So what is,
I saw some word,
what is forward deployment engineer?
Anyone can explain to me that's a new
role which has come recently, right?
So, ma'am, forward deployment.
Are you also?
Engineer, the concept which they are,
you know, propagating is basically you,
you know,
sit beside the stakeholders who is giving
requirement and on and side by side as
the requirement can continuously build
and test and deploy. So, basically,
I mean, there is a slight difference, but.
..
They are actually deployed at the
customer side or at the site where the
actual development is being done.
That is what I heard.
Okay, so.
So basically,
they have to be experts in the
infrastructure,
plus also have the end-to-end delivery
responsibility integration.
End-to-end deployments, right?
Especially whenever the product includes
an AI model.
Right.
E.
Makes OK, they make AI go for production.
They also understand the requirements,
help customers integrate with the AI
products. OK, yeah, whiteboarding. Yeah,
of course,
everyone of us are doing whiteboarding.
Yes, so, so when talking about the shift.
We are talking about more on the product
manager to developer blur,
but there is other shift also.
The developer QA and the operations,
they are all becoming one workflow, right?
A single engineer can orchestrate all of
these activities.
Or a group of people can understand the
end-to-end understanding,
because the hard work.
is going to be done by an AI agent.
We have to only validate, refine,
and approve.
Then it becomes individual contributors
become more, right?
So what all this is leading us to is to
rethink the careers, right? In the past,
career progression was more on technical
depth.
There were Java specialists,
senior Java engineers, C developers,
database administrator,
network specialists,
so master of a specific technology
defined seniority right now,
though they all...
knowledge which has been used or gained
by them will be there.
It will not disappear,
but it won't be sufficient. Tomorrow,
senior engineers will be recognised more
than the Java syntax or semantics for
something different,
their understanding of the entire system.
how they are able to evaluate an entire
AI generated solution, how they
have a judgement across not only of the
code, but across architecture, security,
infrastructure, user experience,
compliance.
So can you write code will never be the
question anymore, but it will be,
can you recognise whether the system is
trustworthy?
Where are the system,
is this system entirely reliable?
How resilient is it to failure?
So those are the questions which will go
to the senior engineers more.
So the roles are getting less siloed.
Plus, there are,
you have to rethink on the work we are
doing on the how seniority is going to be
defined, right? So,
it is going to be more of...
validation, refinement, etc.
Right, so now.
One question I always had,
I would like to hear from some of you.
So if this is for seniors, seniors have,
say, for example,
those who are there in the industry for
maybe 4 plus years of experience or even
2 plus years of experience. You have some
knowledge you have acquired by working on
the system.
And then now you have to expand,
the T shape is not going to work more.
We call it as T skill, right?
So that level of syntax, that is not,
that specialist.
is not gaining much momentum,
so you have to have a complete
understanding of the system.
But what is it for newer engineers who
are going to come to the field or any
fresher who's going to join?
Like, what,
what skill do you think they should?
Quiet.
Yeah, VARSHNEY ANUPRIYA. Yeah, go ahead.
better understanding of the entire system
design rather than just any one coding
I think.
language.
Right.
Any other ffe?
Yeah, ma'am, hi.
So I think if we stick to basics,
like my colleague rightfully said,
we need to have proper understanding of
system designs and how each component
interact with each other.
So that will be more than enough because
all the...
Let us say,
let's call the containers or the
microservices,
all the services can be developed
independently by AI agents.
So we must know how to configure them and
how do they talk with each other and how
well they integrate with each other.
Right.
And one more thing is the knowledge of
the amount of tools available outside.
So that would also add a value in future
because there are so many,
the technology is upgrading,
previously it used to upgrade every six
months or so,
but now it's upgrading every two weeks.
So even days, in fact.
So we should be aware of all the
technology stack and tools available.
And yeah,
basically the newer generation needs to
focus on that.
Right,
so some some answers I see prompt how to
prompt engineering is something they
should believe, right? So.
So now coming back to all your answers,
how do I,
so if I'm just concentrating on using the
AI,
I understand the overall system and say I
understand how the entire system design
works as VARSHNEY said,
and I truly understand the tools which
are available and I promptly
I understand wrong strategies, etc.
How do I evaluate that whatever AI is
writing?
is the most optimised better code.
How does that knowledge or how do a
fresher who's not worked in projects
before the AI era and has completely
generated code using AI, right,
lead the education aspect because we,
I mean, that's a very big.
Yeah.
Different aspect,
we will not go into that, but...
Most of us have learned many things on
the job, right?
And this skill life has been very less.
So for example, a few times back,
service oriented architecture so post
popular. It was a very short period.
And then
then the skill changed to cloud,
then the skill changed to AI.
So the shelf life of skills are really
short, right?
And most of us acquired many things over
the job, right?
So now if everything in the job is
through the AI,
how do you think a fresher who's entering
the IT industry will be able to
acquire such deep technical knowledge.
He is undercome at 7 months.
Okay.
Yeah, I think in my opinion,
I think it may not be required for people
to get into that deep level of
understanding. Rather,
what might happen is there might be more
and more...
this KPIs and system indicators that will
come into picture,
which will tell us that whether the
solution is right in terms of different
parameters, right?
So since AI is going to write those code,
AI can also test it and we can also use
AI to cheque on the governance.
So basically.
It can give us those parameters,
whether for a particular problem,
the amount of lines it has written,
is it really worth it?
Or it should have been a concise
programme.
So something of that sort is maybe what
is going to come up,
where more and more KPIs will be
established and more governance processes
will be there.
And that's where I think decisioning,
I mean making right decisions would be an
important thing for people who are coming
into this industry.
They have to take the right call whether
this is right in this kind of situation
and all of that.
And I think when we start using these
different kinds of AI solutions for
different problems, agents or anything.
The more and more we use them,
we'll understand what,
how efficient are they,
where they're falling behind and those
kind of things.
So probably this is 1 area, I mean,
this is how the new workforce has to move
towards.
This is where they have to go to areas.
Yeah.
Yes. Yeah,
so I'll read out a few responses.
I agree that there are a few, I think.
Abhinav has said that still they should
be able to understand the logic. That is,
I would not call it as programming skill,
but I would call it as problem solving.
As you rightly mentioned,
syntax or the way you solve that,
the programming logic is not important,
but the problem solving skill,
how do you approach a problem?
How are you going to break it out into?
a problem,
input output approach and how that is
what is more primary because that is
required and irrespective of any AI tool
we get, right?
So they should be able to understand the
requirements used by coding.
That's exactly many of your comments.
as Sreesha has mentioned.
I also agree that Abhinav and VARSHNEY
are touching a bond that it's not easy
for a fresher to come and understand all
those things, right? So today,
even in my class, I always think...
that should I go and just talk about PRD
documents,
spec driven Development and I talked
about API,
how many of them here will be able to
relate to all of that?
If you have not worked in the software
industry for quite some time,
there might be still many things which
you have to.
gain over that, right? So it's not easy.
Just on day one, you get all this.
Of course,
there has to be a learning period.
You have to have an understanding context
why. For example,
let me give you a personal experience.
I was writing React.
based codes when we were doing a few web
applications.
We were writing React codes.
and we were designing applications in one
of the certificate programmes which was
launched in the early days.
We had developed a full-fledged
application to demonstrate end-to-end to
the learners, etc. So during that time,
we didn't have an LLM.
Now when I want to demonstrate a few
things to the
users, I can go give a prompt,
I can develop a POC and use that as a
demonstrative code to the users.
But when I do it today,
the point is how do I understand what LLM
gives me or the agent gives me is the
basic right version.
There are a few mistakes which the agent
is making at this point of time.
So we have not matured.
in that aspect yet.
We still have a lot of work to be done in
that area where one thing all of us
should take away is we have never reached
a point that we can completely trust what
is coming out of AI. As I told you,
I'm reading a lot of experiences.
in LinkedIn and other forums that there
are a few problems which is coming out of
AI. So now today we have a very senior...
knowledge driven engineers who are there,
who are able to evaluate what is coming
out of the AI.
So I can see the code and tell, okay,
this is wrong, or I can see the library,
okay, this is not a library which.
exist or this is not the right way to do
it.
So those are things which I can evaluate
at a faster phase,
but we cannot expect the same thing.
as a pressure or someone who's entering
the IT that she could do that.
So that is where we have to measure a lot.
So today,
guardrails are going to be our saviours.
We cannot trust the AI output as such.
We have to have guardrails. Now,
how guardrails...
can be built.
It can be built only by the context,
all the engineers,
the senior people who have all the
knowledge they have brought in. With that,
we are going to tell if there is an
architecture drift happening,
there is something going out of the spec
driven development only.
person who understands the code line by
line will be able to capture that
immediately and tell, okay,
this is not what is how it should go.
So there should be verification loops,
there should be human checkpoints.
For now, they may be human checkpoints.
for some time down the line it might
become automated checkpoints.
Hey, um.
So that is where the,
because we have to take accountability
now. So when we do a work,
we take complete accountability.
So that is also one of our shift.
But here someone else is doing the work
or a agent is doing the work.
So we have to take accountability.
How will you take accountability?
Right, there's nothing to be,
Dhruv has mentioned, I'm still ashamed of,
and there's nothing to be ashamed,
but it's also very difficult to say that
I wrote this code.
I'm fully responsible for it unless and
until you have the confidence of going
through it line by line, right?
So that is a cultural shift.
like DevOps had a cultural shift in terms
of how people work.
This is also a shift mentally we have to
see.
This is not the code which I have written,
but I verified it.
I am the owner of it now.
So that is very difficult, right?
Debugging AI code obviously takes.
more than six hours.
I have experienced it,
but we are improving it.
So I think we will have to see how better.
So during this course,
we will see what are the best practises.
We will together see what are the ways in
which that debugging.
efforts are reduced and obviously the AI
models are also improving.
So we will get to a phase where...
that we are able to trust on the AI
output.
How the trust can come, right?
Only when you have security cheques,
right? So, say, for example, in airports,
right?
Once you get into the inside the airport,
there are multiple checkpoints.
And.
The entire team, the Air Force team,
the airport team plus the crew is
confident that there are no hazardous
material brought in because they had
those checkpoints, right?
The same confidence cannot be there for a
crew of a.
a train or a bus because they don't have
those guardrails or checkpoints.
The same thing is what we will also.
So if we as a crew need to have the
confidence,
we have to have our guardrails and
checkpoints at the right places so that
when the code enters into our production,
we are confident that there's nothing
wrong.
In that,
so that that's how it will have to be at
this point in time.
Right, so...
Going to the third shift,
this is my this is like my favourite one
also,
because this is also a cultural shift.
My parents or the generation before me,
if you ask any, go to their house.
and ask them how old is this particular
product or they will say at least 10 plus,
right?
So you will show them some radio or you
ask them,
show them a TV and ask when did you buy
this? It will be at least a 10 plus.
So there was.
A concept of repair.
Right, we,
but now we don't have a concept of repair,
right?
If something is has to be is not working,
we only replace very,
that that's how I mean, in my son,
at least he's in grade 7,
so what he does is like, at least that.
Repair is a word they have never heard of,
at least we as a generation,
or I hope I can tell all of you are my
generation looking at the profiles.
So at least we had a few things which we
had repaired and used,
at least in the vehicle aspects or in
terms of fuel.
television and other appliances we had at
home, etc. But the upcoming generation,
if you see, there is no concept of repair.
And even if you go and especially
electronics, consumers, things and all,
if you go today,
we hardly have any repair concept.
It's only either replace the entire thing,
If you see.
appliances like TV,
washing machine or even dishwashers
nowadays,
they have a concept of replacing the
entire electronic board, the motherboard,
etc.
But they don't have anything to repair
much because it's not feasible for them
to repair or they don't have the facility
to repair it.
or it is not possible to repair it at all,
right? So that's the, yeah,
humans still get repaired. Yes,
obviously we have to because it's not
replaceable.
But all our appliances are replaceable,
right? But this shift.
whatever we are seeing in AI,
we don't have the concept of refactoring
or repairing.
If a microservices is not working,
you throw it out, write a new service.
That is what is happening today.
Right, so,
because the time to change that
regenerating code is very cheap than the
time to debug,
as well through what someone I forgot,
debugging is 6 hours, right? So,
debugging a refracted or not working code
is going to take more.
time.
So instead of that you can in seconds you
can build a new.
one, right?
So that is why we have more disposable
services today and we don't have any
refractoring happening at all.
And also.
The positive side of it is the other,
its decisions are hard to change.
Say for example, by mistake,
I chose a wrong framework,
or there is a database problem.
If there is a database structure problem,
in those days,
it's very difficult to change,
or even till today in our legacy
applications,
you want to add a new field to a database
or you want to change the structure of a
database, it's very difficult to do that,
right? But today it's possible, right?
We want to normalise the database to
avoid the problem later.
All these questions which had
Heavy weight took hours of discussion
with the stakeholders to change that.
The refactoring efforts were measured in
days and months, or hours at least.
But now,
if you want to change the technology,
you do it immediately.
If you want to change anything,
you do it immediately. So decisions,
there is no writing on the stone concept.
Anything is not written on stone.
We can immediately write it, erase it,
and redo it. That's a very profound shift,
I would say.
to disposable microservices.
The architecture,
the errors become less impactful.
We are able to correct it much.
And there is no lock-in,
lock language or vendor lock-in that has
been erased out completely. Earlier also,
we had erased it out when such open
specifications like API,
The earlier.
In the first phase of service-oriented
architecture,
making a Java service to talk to a Java
client was itself very difficult.
It cannot talk to a Python client or a
JavaScript client. But slowly,
when open standards came in,
we were able to do that more easily.
So we didn't worry about the framework or
the vendor lock-ins, et cetera.
But now it has been erased completely,
right?
You want to shift from one thing to the
other, you can do it immediately.
Remember how cross-platform applications
were there and all iOS,
they used to have an iOS team,
they used to have an Android team.
They have to both be always in sync.
Right?
So those are very changes that are very
difficult to maintain at some point in
time.
Database schemas became more flexible.
They are not any more difficult to change.
You can,
they can also evolve along with this
thing.
So ORM models can be updated easily.
What is ORM?
object relational model.
How do you connect your backend code to
the persistent databases like no SQL
databases or SQL databases, etc. Right.
So code is now abundant and it has become
more of a disposable commodity.
Same song.
So that is how it has evolved.
So we are now incremental cleanup,
small improvements, don't refactor,
try to rewrite it.
So the new mindset for architects is,
they don't stop designing.
carefully, right?
The responsibility shifts.
It's easy to migrate, easier to,
easy to replace.
So they have to be more loosely coupled,
right? So it is always,
there is a famous scene among software
architects.
I don't know if you have heard of.
There are no perfect architecture.
It is all trade-offs. You take one,
you take security,
or you take the availability.
Either one you choose.
That's always a trade-off, right?
So the same wisdom holds true today also.
But AI changes the economics of those
trade-offs.
Regeneration is becoming inexpensive.
Architecture becomes an experiment rather
than a commitment.
So earlier if an architect makes a
mistake and once they implement it,
they want to go and change that to a
different pattern, it's very difficult.
They cannot do that, right?
So, but now it's possible. So,
that's the third shift,
or we are seeing the shift in outside the
technical aspect also,
as we have started the discussion with.
Yes, DHARSHINI, you want to say something?
Go ahead.
Yes, ma'am.
So when we are concentrating on
regeneration, then refactoring,
will that not result in duplication of
efforts?
They, they, of course, yes,
but the effort is being very less,
no duplicate. See, when you spend,
maybe there is an engineer who wrote.
a developer who wrote a microservice for
say, two, three days or a week, that is,
we are again asking another engineer to
spend a week time to do that.
Then it's a duplication of effort.
But now we are asking agent to do that in
two, 3 minutes.
So that is where this entire shift is.
Coming in.
Not with developers doing that.
With the AI doing it,
Yeah.
that is where the decisions have become
hard.
They are no more hard to change or they
are more on refactoring that,
regenerating the other than refactoring.
Yes, ma'am. Thank you.
So earlier, no one will agree, right?
I spent one week to write a code.
I go and ask that, no, no,
this is not how it works.
The architects will be bombarded with so
many questions and the efforts were
mentioned in HARSH, etc.
It's very difficult to do that. But now,
because it's an agent, we...
We can casually go and ask,
please throw this out and write a new one.
That's the.
Okay,
so the 4th shift we will talk about is on
the accountability.
It becomes more foggier, right?
It, I did I miss a few questions?
I'm just...
It will be go through this.
I didn't know when did Abhinav and Varun
Rahul mention these comments.
Maybe we'll come back to that later.
Coming to the 4th shift,
if AI creates the artefacts,
who will own the consequences?
Who's accountable when things break?
Or how do we enforce governance?
We have seen implementation is no longer
the bottleneck; roles become less siloed,
architecture is changeable, adaptable,
right? So...
This is not a technical question.
This is more of a human question, right?
You build it, you run it.
But now, what actually happens?
We have the AI was generating writing the
code, but we cannot. Can we blame the AI?
Can we blame the prompt?
Or can we blame the model itself?
The answer is actually no.
The accountability still remains with the
human.
The nature of accountability also changes,
right?
So earlier we had accountability through
authorship. So I wrote 5 lines of code,
I'm the author of the code.
But now the accountability is through
verification and sign-off, right?
So I wrote
5 lines of code. Sorry, AI wrote 10,
15 lines of code.
I verified it and I signed off it.
So the accountability is shifted.
But still humans are accountable.
We cannot blame the AI,
we cannot blame the prompt,
or we cannot blame the model because we
are doing the verification and sign off.
You may no longer write that line of code,
but we are completely responsible that
every line behaves correctly.
GURURAJ says model vendor.
Can we go and ask Anthropic and these
people that your model didn't give us the
right code?
We cannot make them accountable.
So they will not even look at that aspect.
Of course,
they will take it as a feedback if they
want improvement,
but they will not be accountable.
The accountability will be still ours.
Right.
Imagine we had a software project 10
years ago.
And the developer has written a query or
concatenates user input into a SQL query.
Then there is an SQL injection
vulnerability which has occurred or
attackers exploit a vulnerability SQL
injection attached with the.
User code, etcetera.
The investigation will run,
version control will identify who wrote
that particular line of code.
Responsibility will be straightforward.
A depth now in the AI era,
what will happen?
Say I want to implement an authentication
model. I write a prompt,
ask the AI agent to implement
authentication.
The AI might recommend a package with a
name almost identical to an open source
trusted library.
Everything will look fine.
and to look legitimate at first glance.
But the package sometimes might not even
exist,
which will at least be captured in
testing.
But what if the package is malicious?
It's a bigger problem, right?
That's how security vulnerabilities are.
Supply chain attack is one thing,
but the other thing is the security
vulnerability.
you, if the package is not even mentioned,
that's a different case.
At least you will, when you audit it,
you will be able to find it, etc.
An AI model might bring,
write an hallucinated library dependency,
which contains malware.
The approving human there is fully
accountable for the dependencies,
forcing a shift, right?
So how do we solve this problem?
So how do we ensure such vulnerabilities
doesn't go or before sign off you get?
Just cheque, etcetera.
Any idea, anyone?
I think we need to define that in these
specifications and be provided in the
context and tell the agent to take care
of the security things when something is
being developed.
I didn't get your full response.
Your voice was a little table like.
Yes.
Great.
Okay.
Is it okay now?
It is okay, but it's still too low.
Can you come closer to the mic, probably,
or?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's all good now.
Yes, I think that would work.
It is a little feedback.
Is it?
Don't let the work to become black box.
Yeah, you understand it. So that's right.
My question is very specific.
So you ask AI to develop something.
It gives you a hallucinated package or it
gives you an untrusted open source
library, which is similar,
looks like similar to an open source
library.
Um.
How do you solve this particular problem?
Any inputs?
We define the security constraints in the
specification or context. OK, so,
so you basically you write guard rates is
what you are mentioning,
like you have a cheque.
Right.
Yes, yes.
Yes, have AI checklist in the config file.
That's exactly right.
So there is something called as.
Security Application Testing.
Um...
So.
It it gives you a static testing,
so all of you can.
Search and read about this SAS Static
Application Security Testing. So,
what exactly Static Application Security
Testing will do is,
it's a deterministic cheque.
It's a white box method that will scan
all the...
uncompiled source code,
byte codes or binary.
It identifies all security workflows.
I just type the...
full name in the chat box.
For you all to go and read about it in
detail.
It's a deterministic approach, right?
It helps developers fix security issues
completely.
It goes through all internal code path,
data flow,
early detection is one of the benefits
here, etc. Now, this static applications,
security testing is to secure software by
reviewing it completely.
And it cheques for all,
and there is a dynamic application
testing also happening,
which is more for black box testing.
There, there,
it focuses more on the functionality
aspect of it, right?
So now this testing can still is
something which we can apply as a
guardrail, right? Yeah, sonar cube, yes,
it is not completely security testing.
Sonar cube is a static.
code analyzer, right?
It also cheques on your what kind of code
you want. Of course it does security.
It also does many other things,
like it also cheques on quality code
smells, if there are any complex code.
Or, if there is any missing parts,
some it also cheques for standards,
whether you are writing as per the
standards of your company, all that. Yes,
SUNITA Cube is a tool we use for it,
right? And there are other, yeah,
many of you are.
Giving examples where our code,
pen testing, PMD cheque styles, etc. So,
how do you ensure accountability?
We have to have our checkpoints. So,
when we are generating code,
we have to take away or have...
idea that we are accountable and we
should always have these checkpoints
built so that we are confident.
that it is happening.
The same applies not only for security
vulnerability,
the same applies for compliance also.
Compliance is about evidence and not just
intent, right?
Accountability becomes even more critical
there. For example, regulatory compliance,
banking, insurance, healthcare.
We have to ensure that there is no way we
are deviating from that particular
compliance. We can never say AI wrote it,
especially when it comes to regulatory
compliance, et cetera.
So we should again there have
deterministic verification points.
Though the output is probabilistic and
non-deterministic,
organisations have to depend on
deterministic verification suits,
automated compliance testing,
validation pipelines.
We should be able to cheque at all points.
Um...
Since human cannot explain every AI
synthesised code pathway,
accountability will come or
accountability can be ensured by doing
automated compliance deterministic
cheques.
So deterministic verification suits are
what.
Even regulatory bodies are demanding
today,
and that's how we have to ensure that our
code isn't aligned with the HIPAA or GDPR,
all those compliance tools, et cetera.
And the sign off culture, right?
The PR request sign off, right?
What do we do? If a human rights court,
there is a PR approval process.
We just look at it with some basic things
and we
approve it. Now with AI writing the code,
the same sign off,
but pull requests become more approval
basis. Traditionally,
pull requests will be rename this
variable, use a different loop,
or peer reviews.
on the code, et cetera. Right now,
the human reviewer should look.
more careful on those checkpoints.
Could this be a security vulnerability?
Is this deviating any regulatory
compliance?
Are there some unusual edge cases?
Are there some edge cases which are
verified?
So the approval will have a line saying,
I have verified the system to the best of
my professional judgement.
That is how it should be.
So the new responsibilities of engineers
would be more on validation.
They become validators rather than
developers. They become auditors,
risk managers, right?
So that is where it includes right from
ethics.
security, compliance,
all those things will come into picture.
So this is the 4th.
The final shift is now the outputs are
becoming more probabilistic in nature.
They are not going to be saying,
you ask the question or I ask the
question,
we are not going to get a single answer.
We are going to get different answers.
So generative models,
all models are non-deterministic, right?
So, but software engineering,
Has always been deterministic logic
construction. Right now,
it is becoming more of probabilistic.
harness engineering and guard railing.
We build deterministic evaluators and
defensive wrappers around the
non-deterministic AI agents and that's
what they call that this harness and
guard railing all that is what they are
saying it today.
So earlier, a pass or fail unit test,
verify, fix logic outputs, etc.
Now teams are writing evaluators that run
hundreds of variations against AI outputs
to measure the pass rate.
So they are saying this agent produces
secure, functionable code 98% of the time,
right? So there is a confidence interval.
The software quality is becoming as a
confidence interval.
And earlier we had the strongly typed
compilers, which caught the logical.
mistakes, mismatch at the compile time.
Right now we have dynamic runtime
enforcers, we have rate limiters,
we have schema validators,
which can look at the non-deterministic
LLM runtime outputs before they hit the
production DBs, etc.
So I was recently looking at a project by
one of your senior PAUL.
members.
The student wanted was running a LLM for
a for a banking application related
application, finance related, not banking.
It's a FinTech kind of an application.
So the student wanted to ensure
that there are no,
they already have a rule-based engine.
So that student wanted to ensure that
whatever can be checked by the rule-based
engine should be checked by the
rule-based engine and whatever cannot be
resolved within that only should go to
the LLM or.
the outside AI aspect.
And also they wanted to enforce that.
The input to the LLM is only JSON based
on the content.
The context goes in form of a JSON only,
so it's precise.
They don't miss on anything,
so that the output can be more
deterministic in nature.
So that kind of a cheque is what they are
building.
So,
so everyone is trying to build a wrapper
around the AI agent,
a deterministic wrapper,
which is built around that,
and that is that that is what most of the
AI engineering today is looking at,
so they are looking at ways in which...
the output can be more trusted,
how you can write more deterministic
evaluation cheques to the output which is
coming in.
So instead of engineering teams,
Writing the unit test,
now we are writing evaluation suites
called as evals.
They cheque for the variation and they
tell that what is the confidentiality
score.
And earlier we prevented errors from
reaching the production.
By compiling compiler cheques with the
unit testing and other all kinds of tests,
etc. Now,
since responses every time it is created
dynamically,
we also have to dynamically cheque,
so we have to have validators there,
rate limiters there, permission systems,
because...
Dynamically,
the output is coming to an LLM.
So for example, say something like.
I would say the same finance example I
will take,
they want to have the best recommended
mutual fund system for the customer.
So it goes to an LLM,
it goes through a rule-based classifier
and then it goes to an LLM and output
comes. But what if
The output is itself is generated
dynamically.
So how do you ensure that you don't give
any wrong information to the end user?
So only through guardrails and
checkpoints, right? So you install safe,
better safety systems around your,
that's what end type.
harness engineering is about.
You don't remove the AI aspect,
but you are building a safety circle
around the AI aspect.
The software engineering brings the
discipline, the AI brings the creativity,
but software engineering is bringing the
discipline around it. And that's what
We are talking,
we will be talking about that and more
how to bring that discipline,
but that's still required today is what
the message I want you all to take
forward.
Other example for this also would be on
the prompt.
aspects. Better prompts solve everything.
That is the assumption we have.
Proms alone are not the architecture.
Of course, prompts are important,
but it is not the complete.
thing. Natural language,
correct natural language alone cannot
guarantee a system state, etc.
So you have to have the wrapper around it.
So that is also we have to pick state
missions, workflows,
how do we monitor the workflows,
how do we correct it.
the feedback loop,
how it goes back to the AI,
to when it performs the reasoning.
So how do we ensure more deterministic
cheques is what is more important. So.
To summarise all of these things.
Traditional.
Systems or software engineers programmed
certainty. AI software engineers,
they engineer more on confidence.
So the shift AI makes coding inexpensive.
So software engineering shifts from
writing code to inventing, validating,
and filtering out the best solutions.
So we are end-to-end owners orchestrating
different agents.
So these,
the future of software engineering or the
way we look at software engineering is
changing or it has to change.
It cannot no more be the same what we had
been looking at in the previous.
before the shift head up.
Right, so how do we rethink?
What is the enduring?
This is the question I asked all of you,
but in aspects of a fresher,
but in aspect of a.
When code generation is cheap and
outcomes are probabilistic,
the single most valuable skill for a
software engineer today, according to me,
would be system design and verification
judgement or engineering evaluation.
So you are not...
generators, you are validators.
So when AI can bring out thousands of
lines of code, the bottleneck is shifted.
So it is to decide what to build,
structure, how systems interact.
And how do you verify the probabilistic
outputs and meet the requirements?
So code writer to code auditor.
Harness is what we will discuss more
about, designing evals and guardrails.
Non-deterministic models,
how do you ensure that they are matching
your requirements?
System thinking over syntax mastering.
Intent into rigorous specification,
the documentation example we talked about,
right? So the documentation is,
we are not writing for humans,
we are writing for...
agents or AI. So it has to be more clear,
more rigorous specification has to be
there.
You have to break down the real world
problem,
think how it will be solved into precise
technical specifications.
Unambiguous conditions,
so that the hallucination is not being.
But.
affecting our systems, etc.
So.
That's the shift I want to talk about.
So quickly, on whatever we discussed,
there is one paper I want all of you,
whenever you have time to go through,
that is the rethinking Software
Engineering for Agent TKI systems.
I've given you the link here.
The paper, it's openly available.
It's a small read-up only,
but it I felt that it has nicely
summarised this aspect for Agent TKI
systems. So, to give you a small...
It's almost the same repeated thing we
have been discussing, but...
I would just summarise it now,
but you can go and read it more, etc.
So this paper,
the rapid maturation of the LLMs has
fundamentally changed the paradigm,
so it accepts that, right?
So code has become a disposable commodity.
And now how do you,
the entire software engineering,
how this discipline as such should
reorganise, right?
And they are giving three main
competencies based on which we should
reorganise. One is the orchestration part,
verification,
and human AI collaboration.
So these are the three core competencies,
right? So as I mentioned,
the shift is clear.
Now we know the shift from syntax to
intent.
It is more on orchestration and
accountability is still ours. So we are,
we are.
clear about that on the shift.
So that is what is characterised here as
the inversion of the engineering value.
Now verification is the new bottleneck,
right?
If you look at this particular diagram,
the inversion of engineering value,
that itself is very clear.
All right,
so it shows the fundamental shift, right?
So here you see that in 2020s or the
earlier paradigms before the AI era,
60% of the engineering value was based on
the syntax mastery and language
constructs.
And 10% was dedicated to system
architecture and intent.
Now in the AI Augmented one,
the distribution is flipped.
60% of values lies in the system curation,
verification, governance, compliance.
And since AI is doing the code generation,
automated syntax production has
come to a smaller fraction,
10% of the value chain.
Right,
because code has become a disposable
commodity,
this is where we are becoming an
implementer to more of a navigator,
more of an orchestrator,
and verification has become the core
competency.
Verification replaces authorship,
and verification is the new primary.
bottleneck now, right?
Because AI generated code is often
syntactically correct.
It is not wrong at all,
but it is semantically flawed.
So how do you ensure that it is right?
So accountability has become the human
component.
because that's what we have to.
The inversion is here,
you see it is the elevation of the
profession itself.
Many might feel that we are software
engineer jobs,
or you might hear comments that software
engineer jobs run out.
You might not have software engineers.
But many of the people whom I'm reading
or personally also I feel it's more an
elevation of the profession itself.
You are becoming,
instead of doing mechanical syntax
production work,
you are given to do more creative
accountable work required to build
enduring systems. So it's, again,
I would say it's a more an elevation of
the profession rather than thinking of it
as eliminating the profession as such.
So this paper talks about this intent as
well as the inversion.
And it also compares the traditional era
and the agentic era.
So primary artefact there,
it was the scarcity.
Here we have it in abundance,
the code writing skills. So here it is,
the role was authorship.
Now it is more on orchestration.
And the bottleneck is verification and
not anymore writing.
And this is a very important one,
the definition of success, the metrics.
So we have a complete module on metrics.
That's a very, very,
very important or most vital thing we
should discuss. We cannot anymore
measure the performance of an individual
based on the lines of code or the number
of PR.
because that is always going to be there.
So the metrics itself has to be
redesigned. How reliable the system is,
how many are functionally working,
how many don't have any security
vulnerabilities.
So you cannot have the same metrics we
have been using based on the number of
lines of.
code,
measuring a performance of an individual
on the lines of code,
how many they shipped it to date.
That's not what is going to work.
And coming, and another interesting thing,
which I don't know how interesting it
will be for you, but for me as a.
person from the academic side.
This paper also addresses the changes
across education,
how education also should support this.
And one main thing which re-emphasized
our own internal thinking was
The language specific syntax mastery
should be moved towards systems curation,
which should emphasise more architectural
thinking, verification literacy,
and more about receptive programming that
is more on verifying the AI.
generated code rather than writing the
code itself, right? So that is 1 aspect.
So these are the new core competencies,
the articulation and architectural
control verification.
How do you orchestrate?
And how do you ensure accountability and
human management? Now, this change...
This is the core competency,
but this is a change which will not come
only. I mean,
this change is not required only by an
individual.
It's not only the software engineers who
should change or their idea should change.
So there are four dimensions.
This paradigm shift should,
or we should work on 4 dimensions for to
operationalize and work make this
paradigm shift works. First is education,
as I was recently mentioning,
that it should focus more on systems
curation.
So the courses you are taking up
The lifelong learning we are doing should
focus more on systems curation rather
than talking about syntax mastery, etc.
The second shift dimension we have to
look at is the tooling aspect.
Development environments,
which we have been using like VS Code or
anything, they no longer cannot be just
Um...
code editors.
They have to turn into orchestration
platforms.
They should be provide built-in
verification.
They should have a tracking system.
They should have human in the loop
control points.
So the tooling system also has to evolve.
Plus,
the processes, right?
We had a traditional agile waterfall
model.
All those things have to transition to
spec driven development where human
author technical specifications will
serve as the ground single source of
truth that agents will implement.
Plus it should also bring in
human-in-the-loop life cycles,
verification-first approaches.
So earlier we had trust-driven
development, behavior-driven development,
all those things.
So now it should focus more on the
spec-driven development where you have
the verification-first approach, etc.
And the last is the metrics and the
professional practises.
So you cannot no longer measure based on
line of code or PR throughput,
but by decision, velocity, reliability,
business outcomes,
that is how you should be verified.
evaluating the metrics.
The metrics should actually be redefined
for the AI Augmented SDLC.
So,
that's what a few inputs from this paper,
which rethinks the software engineering.
It's a very good read,
so please go through it whenever you have
some time.
Okay,
so I have another 10 minutes or even less
than that. I don't want to rush through,
but quickly I will talk about the
economics side of it.
I will not go into detail. I will, anyway,
we will talk about economics in detail
later.
Okay,
so as we talked about general shift in
terms of efforts,
in terms of human accountability,
all that. But when it comes to cost also,
the entire software economics is shifting.
So in order to understand this software
economics,
we have to also understand a little bit
of
how the software economics was calculated
in the past.
So any idea how we used to do,
anyone has experience in calculating cost,
human efforts, how do you build,
et cetera?
Yeah.
Yeah, ma'am, for a traditional software,
we used to actually have an estimation
done on the requirement and then add
resources.
Like if it is like 500 hours is the cost,
we'll give some resources.
Resources will have their billing or,
you know,
part of our cost and that way the
software building.
cost would be there, right?
And then deployment would be,
as mentioned,
is a one-time activity and then it will
be a business as usual.
That is how we used to do for traditional
things.
Yes. So have you heard of COCOMO model,
constructive cost model?
So those are some models we have used in
software engineering in the past.
So it's a quick initial estimation based
on project size and the mode, etc.
Then you,
that's how they initially started with.
Then it had a POCOMO model,
it's a software cost estimation model.
Right from 1981 it was there.
And then it has,
it also has been undergone a few
evaluations.
It has changed suitable for newer people.
etc.
So there are a lot of measurement metrics.
We look at certain,
in terms of human efforts,
how do we mention, how many users we have.
So all that are something we look at.
So once,
so that is on the efforts aspect of it.
Then we have the other aspects on how do
we run the cost cost in building versus
the cost in hosting it.
So if you look at the host hostage cost,
it was always less.
It was only hosting or if you put it in a
cloud,
then there was a little bit of cloud
economics.
which came in,
which actually had increased the running
cost a little bit higher. Earlier,
if you look at the older software,
before even the cloud,
the cost was more on.
the initial building only, right? Yes,
more on CapEx and less on the dynamic
operational cost, etc.
But what changed now is with the cloud
also it changed a little.
The hosting cost went a little higher,
but now it is much more even higher
because you are running AI modules.
They are bringing in a variable.
cost.
You should know how to operationalize it.
You should also should know how to
estimate it.
You have to also ensure that it doesn't
go about the limits.
Cost efficiency has to be measured all
that.
So we'll talk about the cost economics
one in aspects of
the running cost,
that is the 0 marginal cost is software
is not up there.
That is you build it and you don't have 0
cost.
That is not going to be there anymore.
Even in the cloud era, it was not there.
We had monthly bills come to our systems
every time. Right now we are also getting.
cloud bills plus the AI bills.
So that shift is something we have to
talk about. The second shift is on the...
When the API era came in, right,
whether you are going to build your own
API or you're going to use an API which
is already available,
a third party service,
build versus by Cosmos,
then more when in the API era,
because there is already a third party
service who's providing you that,
why do you need to rebuild that?
You can just use it.
instead of maintaining that.
So the focus was more on build versus buy.
Right,
so internal developer salary cost versus
external vendor subscription.
But now you can build it more easily than
buying it from outside.
So the shift is how much do we have a
human labour?
how can we do a inference cost plus human
verification on what will be the cost if
the entire human is building it.
So that is the second as a major shift in
terms of the cost economics.
So we are not anymore
relying on third party APIs.
That was the API economics,
the cloud economics was very high in
between, right?
Cloud at least it was more on.
Infrastructure,
but still we had a many SAS based company
Software as a service. Also,
we focused more on.
buying things rather than rebuilding it
from scratch, et cetera,
because that was more easier and you can
look at it.
But now with this change which are
happening,
we can see that the shift in terms of
cost will be to see if.
we can generate that code with the lesser
tokens or with the lesser cost, etc.
So you can look at how this shift in the
build versus buy to,
how the baseline equation itself is
shifting to the inference cost plus human
verification cost versus
full human execution cost.
So it is basically token versus human
labour cost. So you have to optimise.
For example, I have a task.
The problem is called as the task model
mismatch. Say I want to do a simple UI.
Oh.
and I use a high tier reasoning model,
it actually based the capital.
Right, but if I use an underpowered model,
I waste human money when developers have
to fix the hallucinations, etc.
So there is always a trade-off, right?
So you have to find out what is the best
one works there, etc.
And the previous shift we talked about,
the 0 marginal shift, it
moves from a fixed CAPEX to a dynamic
OPEX model, etc.
So you have to focus on cost efficiency
per query.
You always will have a running cost,
which is the end of the...
Zero model cost software, etc.
And then the third shift I want to talk
about is on the pricing.
That is where we were GitHub and other
all softwares. If you remember,
it was based on a number of users.
So all many SAS vendors, they had a.
monetize their software based on number
of user count $30 per user per month.
That is how it was. And now,
since agents are doing the actual work,
the seating pricing is reduced and we
have
To look at more on an outcome-based
approach or usage-based model, right? So,
software architects will have to measure
outcomes, not the regular metrics;
they have to measure resolutions,
tasks completed, rather than just a login.
activity, et cetera.
So that's the third shift. Again,
there are a few more shifts from capital
assets to disposable expenses.
The cost of quality,
there is a 80-20 cost inversion is what
they are seeing.
That is writing the first 80% of the
feature.
costed 80% of the budget.
And then last 20%,
that is deploying the software,
cost 20% of the budget in the earlier
economic assumption.
But now if you see generating the 1st 80%
of the functional code base via the API,
Sorry, my other AI.
actually takes only the minimal amount
cost and it is done in lesser time.
But achieving the last 20%,
that is edge cases, 0 hallucination,
compliance, all that,
consumes 95% or more than 80% of the
project budget in
testing and so budget shifts entirely
from feature building to edge case
verification and security auditing.
That's what is the shift also.
So we have to talk about more of this.
We have to see what are the productivity
gains.
and also see the return on investment,
how it is going to go further.
That is what we will discuss in cost
economics as we,
after we get a basic understanding of AI.
I felt it's too early to talk too much
about this at this point in time.
we have to get into some hands-on
practise and then we'll come back to the
first is what I felt.
So I'll just keep it very minimal and
superficial at this point in time. Right.
So with that, I close for this week.
So these are the risks which we are
encountering.
So some names might be very new to you.
For some of you,
the code slop is something which we are
hearing again and again, right?
What is code slop is?
High volume code bloat. That is,
because generating code is virtually free,
they be accept.
complex AI code rather than simple
minimal elegant abstractions.
So this becomes unmaintainable code basis
over time.
And also LLMs evaluate code in a
localised window,
function by function or file by file.
So they have a context blindness.
They lack a macro level awareness of the
entire domain driven system or the entire
microservices architecture, et cetera.
So over reliance on AI to continuously
correct many legacy systems.
or large code bases can mask a few
underlying architectural flaws leading to
unnecessary code technical depth.
So this architectural drift or unchecked
technical depth is what is called us.
the code slot.
So what is architectural drift is nothing
but a gradual diversion between what is
planned theoretically and the implemented
code base. So the drift is happening.
So AI acceleration actually drastically
has been increasing this architectural
drift.
So this is considered one of the major
risks involved.
Majorly it is happening because of
context blindness.
Because you work on localised LLMs,
work on localised files.
or localised code bases,
so they don't get the complete picture.
So that is when a little bit of context
blindness is coming.
And context memory is also a problem.
They don't have very big context memory.
Each model has their own limitations.
So that is where this problem actually
comes in.
So because generating code is faster,
They regenerate.
helper functions, ORM mappings,
again and again, they don't reuse.
So the code base blocks exponentially
leading to code slots, etc.
And so that is one of the risks and the
human fatigue we have been discussing
about from the beginning, right?
So when you have to verify so much code,
you become like a rubber stamper in the,
similar to the office clerks who just
seal that. So that is how it is becoming,
approving code without auditing its
alignment with long-term system
architecture, et cetera.
So those are some problems.
which are risks which are involved.
So we have to find out ways,
or we have to discuss best practises
which are done in the industry to
eliminate these risks, et cetera.
So code quality and security
vulnerability is the first risk.
that is we discussed about this
hallucinated packages,
not writing secure code,
missing certain security vulnerabilities.
We even discussed one solution that is
automated security testing,
missing edge cases.
So these are some problems in the code.
Then in the design,
the port slope and architectural drift.
Then humans,
when it comes to human factor,
the fatigue and the cognitive risks are
there. Apart from this,
there is compliance and legal risk which
is there.
So you have to ensure all the legal
compliance is followed, etc.
And the last is the economic and the
operational risk, vendor lock-ins,
review bottleneck,
then how do you ensure that there is a
variable?
token explosion is not there.
So the entire tokenomics,
that is what they call token maxing is a
problem. So we have to discuss all that.
So these are some of the risks which are
involved.
Okay, so every phase of the SDLC,
we are going to see how these risks can
be eliminated. First,
we'll see what are the risks and how
these risks can be eliminated.
That's what we will do.
K.
So I've given the reference paper,
major paper, which talks about that.
So, I'll stop here today.
So as I mentioned,
next class we will start with a few
foundations of AI. That is,
we will talk about LLM.
We'll talk about the transformer context
memory, the tokens, etc.
And once we complete that,
we will start with
each phases of stSemAIMLstudentsdocs.
We'll start with the requirements and
design, and then we'll go to coding,
et cetera.
That's how we'll proceed with the entire
course.
What sort of assignment we would be doing?
The rough idea is...
You will take a problem statement.
We will go through all the phases of SDLC
with the help of AI at each phase.
for that particular problem statement.
And you will reflect,
there will be reflection questions.
You will reflect on what you have
identified, what you gone through,
and you will also submit the artefacts
which you had generated.
That is how it will be.
More details about it,
I will give you on a iterative
I will give it to you in an incremental
fashion,
probably 2 phases I will give it to
before medicine and for the other phases
we will do it postmates.
Okay.
Okay, then. Thank you all.
We'll meet again next week.